what's up glider fans I'm here with the
legendary the goat the greatest Jeff
Jones himself how are you doing today
good how you doing I'm doing great
so I just want to say right off the back
I love the first couple episodes I got
to see I love Starfire she was a
breakout star for me so how was it
bringing these characters to life how
did it feel because me personally like
growing up seeing Teen Titans and Teen
Titans go to see them live-action just
blew my mind yeah it blows my mind too I
mean especially Starfire mention her I
love that we kept her storyline under
wraps so no one really know what we're
doing with her and she's she's so good
like when she wakes up and and you start
to realize she doesn't know who she is
and then you see the big payoff in the
first episode it's pretty awesome you
guys stop what you stopped watching this
interview and go watch that episode come
back because the star fighter kills it
but it just in general what can we
expect to see with these characters
storylines as the show progresses from
from episode 2 and on we're in the pilot
you see like it's um it's really Dick
Grayson dealing with his internal
darkness that he's kind of built up over
the years of working with Batman and
then he comes across this girl who has
her own internal darkness that's a
literal internal darkness and she's
looking for help and he's a little bit
or he's a lot reluctant to take on
somebody young like Bruce did with him
because it didn't go so well in his mind
and now he's trying to figure out how
can I help this girl and and it's gonna
be me or there's gonna be other people
and the course of the series he learns
that it's going to take more than just
him to help Rachel we get a couple hints
at at Bruce Wayne throughout well is
there any possibility that we might see
him pop up on the show as Batman or just
Bruce Wayne in general there's always a
possibility I like that answer I love
that answer and I and I've asked a
couple of other cast members I guess it
wouldn't really pertain to you about
guest starring on another show but if
you could take one of the Titans and put
them on like dune patrol or something
like that which are the original crew
would you put on another show
well Beast Boy you know comes from nuuma
troll and so when we meet Beast Boy we
really meet him in episode 4 where you
get to meet the Douma troll
- so you see him already in that world
so it makes sense for him to guest star
on that show but I mean I don't know it
it'd be super fun I think to have I'd
rather take like you know daredevil and
have them to get starring Titans that
would be crazy
oh yeah yeah daredevil let's put let's
get that MCU DC crossover that would be
amazing I would love to do that I don't
think the powers that be will ever let
that happen but I'd love to see it so
what was your favorite episode of the
first season it's hard I like everyone
for different reasons but my probably my
personal favorite I don't know it's
tough I do really like the episode it's
a Hawk and Dove episode I wrote that
Akiva Goldsman directed and it's all
about just those two characters and I
and the reason I am really proud of that
episode is because the script was very
personal to me and the idea the story
personal to Akiva two deals with grief
and loss and codependency and it takes
two characters and I don't think people
really know I caulk and of like people
probably just look at Hawk and Dove and
glaze over right but I love taking those
characters that are more minor and we're
outside the box you know that people
don't really pay attention to and dig
really deep deep into who they are and
explore them and introduce some of the
people and hopefully by the end of the
episode they'll be people who who say I
love walking down and when I finished
episode 2 when we really got to see them
for the first time I was like I could
see why they wanted a spin-off for them
or a show for their own because it's
just like they work together their
chemistry together everything works and
the fight choreography with them was
just ain't like superior so when coming
up with the PI choreography for them was
there something like specific you had in
mind something you wanted to mimic or
rubber pay from inspire from other shows
or yes I mean a fight was gonna be more
brutal more like real but also hyper
realized with Hawk and Dove specifically
it was like Hawk is a bull in a china
shop no matter where he is it's a china
shop compared to Hawk you know and Dove
is more graceful she's got a dancing
background and
martial arts and so and she's kind of
untouchable
you know it's almost like Hawk to take
hits and keep fighting and of no one can
touch her and and the way they work
together you can see you know Doug come
in there and they they almost do a dance
yeah in a way and we continue that on
when we see them further but there are
specific you know fight the fight
choreography is amazing but they're
specific styles at each one of the
characters has when it comes to fighting
if you could pick one of the characters
to play as or like if your favorite hero
from the Titans like to have power to
take their powers or anything like that
which one would you pay oh if I got to
have the powers of one of the characters
it's hard to say I mean turning you know
Tiger is pretty cool but um I don't know
they're all interesting I almost would
want to be robbed and just have that
skill set you know just to be like a
like a martial artist and and and not
like a quadruple shooting fire or Ravens
demonic powers or even demonic powers I
feel like I probably like unleash those
accidentally and screwed things up maybe
start fire powers this would be cool but
then you're burning stuff all the time
and that's true you know Beast Boy
turning to Tiger I think would be cool
but if someone comes across you like
they might you know freak out there's a
tiger in the room I don't know you know
who knows they're all cool and then and
specifically with Starfire I know you've
probably seen like why does she have
green bolts or like from the animation
or anything like that will we ever see
ever have green to green powers or
anything better or is it gonna just
always say it with with the fire like it
might evolve into that but really that
she's just learning Hydra powers work
cuz she's forgotten it's using human
soul about battery you know and she
absorbs the sunlight her eyes go green
and her she turns into a star fire you
know her orange skin glows orange and
everything else and and we'll see her
look evolve as we go but so far her
powers
you know her powers are manifesting in a
kind of a more grounded way I think
those are perfect way to approach it
thank you so much for talking with me
Jeff I really enjoyed this oh and I
can't wait for everybody else to see